for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out move
university comm thank you and enjoy
previously we mentioned that THF could
donate a methyl group from an 5-methyl
THF but that it wasn't a particularly
good methyl group donor in this video
we're going to talk about how a s
adenosylmethionine or sam is basically
the primary methyl group donors the
preferred methyl group donor and it's
the one that pretty much does all the
methyl group donation and it looks like
this this is Sam right here this portion
of the molecule comes from the amino
acid methionine so this portion right
here specifically as a sidechain and so
that that sidechain has a methyl group
attached to the sulfur and that's going
to actually be the 1 carbon group that
we donate that's gonna be the actual
methyl group that's going to be donated
and then the rest of the molecule here
comes from adenosine which is a
nucleoside ok now Sam is not a vitamin
in the way that the other two one carbon
donors biotin and THF are well why is
that why why is it not a vitamin well
it's because our cells can actually make
it and part of the definition of a
vitamin one of the defining features of
the vitamin is that it cannot be made by
ourselves
it must be consuming our diet so how is
it that we can make it let's check this
out
okay so we'll start at the top left here
with methionine start over here with
methionine we've labeled that one carbon
group in red so we can keep track of it
so we'll start off with the methionine
and ATP to basically get to basically
make meth I mean so let's do some arrow
pushing here let's do the arrow pushing
in turquoise color here so this sulfur
will nucleophilically attack this carbon
right here on adenosine causing these
electrons to hang out on oxygen
basically kicking off a triphosphate
group as a leaving group that will be
the leaving group or LG abbreviate that
there so that triphosphate group comes
off and that's already kind of weird
that's not usually what we see when the
nucleophile attacks ATP it normally
comes and I'll do this in a different
color it would normally come in and
attack phosphorus right kicking off an
inorganic pyrophosphate but that's not
what's happening here so this reaction
is already kind of weird worth noting
that okay anyway so that that the
triphosphate leaving group comes off and
that is hydrolyzed off into an organic
phosphate and then an organic
pyrophosphate that portion those two
aspects of the reaction the combining of
methane Aneta ATP kicking off this
leaving group and hydrolyzing the
triphosphate group into an inorganic
phosphate and inorganic pyrophosphate is
catalyzed by methionine adenosyl
transferase or MIT once you have that
pyrophosphate that can be hydrolyzed off
into two inorganic phosphates by an
inorganic phosphatase or inorganic pyro
phosphatase which I'm not showing here
but I'm saying it anyway that's how we
make s adenosylmethionine or Sam now we
have Sam attached here or we have them
to finally attach to the the adenine
sale portion so we have Sam and that one
carbon group there that methyl group can
be donated okay so we'll start off with
Sam so that that answers the question of
how s adenosylmethionine is made now I
said you know side
y'know soma thymine or Sam acts as a
methyl group donor and when it donates a
methyl group it basically happens like
this we'll start off with sama and some
species that doesn't have a methyl group
that needs a methyl group and so that
that that methyl group requirement will
be satisfied by a Sam it'll give up its
methyl group to that species making that
species that initially didn't have a
methyl group now it has one and when Sam
loses that methyl group it becomes a
Cedeno still homeless cysteine or SAH
okay so now that one carbon group is
gone and this would be catalyzed by a
methyl transferase some methyl
transferase dependent often named for
whatever it is that we're attaching the
methyl group to okay so that gives us a
Cedeno so homocysteine now we can use
this to actually use this in the process
of basically regenerating Sam so the
first product the first step to get that
or to get that to happen is we're gonna
hydrolyze off the adenosine hydrolyze
off the adenosine portion using some
hydrolase and that'll of course that
adenosine comes off and we're left with
just homeless system which is an amino
acid it's not a proto genic amino acid
not one of the twenty that we know to
make proteins but it is an amino acids
got an amino group carboxyl group access
details I'm kind of getting off track
here
anyway this almost this team is very
similar in structure to Matheny it is
basically just missing the methyl group
so all we need to do to get from
homeless cysteine to methionine is to
add a methyl group so we needed a methyl
group donor
this is where n5 methyl THF comes into
play so this n5 methyl THF it's actually
gonna donate its methyl group and become
THF and this reaction requires a
cofactor coenzyme b12 or cobalamin which
is actually this is one of the two
reactions in which this coenzyme b12 is
used and this reaction is catalyzed by
defining synth bass this reaction is of
particular significance because it's
basically to one carbon transfer
cofactors sort of working together right
we got th F and we've got basically Sam
it's not actually Sam working here but
the the holes this is kind of a cycle
here with with Sam I'm getting
regenerated by regenerating a meth I
mean to produce it and that that's sort
of working with the tetrahydrofolate so
it's it's kind of interesting in that
sense I figured I'd note it also this is
the only reaction in which and 5-methyl
THF donates a methyl group so it really
isn't a good methyl group donor but it
donates a methyl group to homocysteine
to crema thymine so we can make Sam
which is the methyl group donor okay
anyway that's about it
I hope that video was helpful thank you
for watching if you found that video
helpful don't forget to Like comment
subscribe and share with friends thank
you and happy studying